المرحله الجميع طبعا يدرك بان اسطنبول هي
المدينه الاكبر في تركيا الخزان الانتخابي
الكبير يقولون دائما الاتراك بان من يفوز
في تركيا فانه هو الذي يفوز في اسطنبول هو
الذي يفوز بكل تركيا وهذا كثيرا ما تحقق
ودائما ما تحقق حتى بالمناسبه جلال عندما
فازت المعارضه فاز الحزب الشعب الجمهوري
ببلديه اسطنبول الكبرى كانت اغلب الاصوات
قد ذهبت لحزب العداله والتنميه او الاصوات
في البلديات الداخليه البلديات المحليه
بمعنى اسطنبول يوجد فيها 49 بلديه 25
بلديه ذهبت لتحالف الجمهور فيما تقاسمت كل
الاحزاب الاخرى بقيه بلديات هذه المدينه
اي ان تركيا والمجلس ايضا للبلدي في بلديه
اسطنبول وايضا العداله والتنميه على الرغم
من ان رئيس البلديه هو من المعارضه
وبالتالي اسطنبول ايضا في انتخابات 2019
ايضا اعطت للعداله والتنميه وان ذهب منها
مقعد رئاسه البلديه الان علينا ان ننتظر
لنعلم اسطنبول ما زالت تؤيد العداله
والتنميه ما زالت تدعم رجب طيب اردوغان
الذي اوصلته في يوم ما الى رئاسه الوزراء
ورئاسه الجمهوريه بعد ان حقق تقدما
وانجازات كبيره هنا عندما اصبح رئيسا
لبلديتها في عام 94 الاستقطاب الشديد
والحاد في تركيا والذي بالمناسبه جلال
يتدرج كل سنه على الاخرى بمعنى نسبه
الاقبال في تركيا في انتخابات 2011 كانت
تقريبا 83 في انتخابات 2015 وصلت الى 85
بالمئه في انتخابات السابقه 2018 وصلت الى
86% وبالتالي ربما ربما من خلال مشاهدتنا
في المناطق التي زرناها على الاقل في هذا
المركز وفي العديد من المراكز القريبه
يمكن القول بان هذه النسبه قد ترتفع ايضا
في هذه الانتخابات عن 86 مقارنه بانتخابات